[Music]
I'm Jerry Fong I'm a junior MIT and
studying art and design with a minor in
computer science
well I think it's very important for all
sorts of disciplines to be involved with
the launch because the college of
computing isn't just about computation
for example the borderline involves
computation technology all intersecting
with art and design I'm Danny Gelman I
am a junior here at MIT studying
computer science and comparative Media
Studies I have a twin brother who's also
a junior here at MIT we have very
similar career goals and we're studying
pretty much the same thing
my name is Alain Delon art painting
drawing like things like that have
always been really interesting to us so
we thought it was really cool when
borderland was starting a lot of
students at MIT are interested in the
arts but there wasn't really a community
it kind of scattered people doing are in
their dorm room or going to clubs and
doing it on the weekends and the goal
was really to create something that
everyone at MIT could see and be really
proud of it started out in the tunnels
of MIT we wanted to basically make them
be a destination to go to as opposed to
just a means of getting places so we
added murals to the tunnels and then we
animated those murals
when you hold up your phone to the
picture there's another story that takes
place so you get to see an animation
that the student created display over
the actual picture
for the opening of the college of
computing we're having an AR animation
competition and right now we're hosting
the workshop teaching students how to
make AR animations I think it's really
important that people at MIT are aware
that the students are very multifaceted
they have different aspects to their
personalities and different passions and
through this we hope to present a more
whole and well-rounded image of who
students at MIT are
[Music]
you